Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 20th episode today!
20th!
Can you believe it already?
I can't, but you know what's even better than 20 episodes?
What?
22 episodes.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, maybe today's your first time joining us.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Always us.
Pronounced.
Pronounced, you have plans.
But please, Fuwawa.
Please don't.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, if you could please tweet any thoughts, you know, thoughts, feelings, with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
We'd be really happy.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, a new day.
A new day.
And it seems like there's been another Ruffian that spotted Pero.
Ueshi deshita.
I guess, you know, while this Ruffian was on a nice daily walk, they spotted Pero, or... Maybe!
Maybe that's what they think!
He was there and then he just disappeared.
Yeah, that's what they said, you know.
Disappeared as soon as they turned around, but... Are you sure that he was really there in the first place, though?
He's not a ghost.
Well, you know, if you look at all the autumn leaves on the ground already by that bench, it's kind of getting to that time of year, right?
Right!
How though?
It's gone really fast, hasn't it, Moco-chan?
Well, like, summer just ended, so...
And now it's hololive autumn.
I like that too!
Lots of sweaters, warm drinks, sweet potatoes.
Ruffians, if you see Pero, maybe first you should give your eyes a bit of a rub.
Just make sure that it's okay that you're actually seeing him.
Well, at the very least, I think these Ruffians, they're able to have a really nice walk filled with crisp air.
It's nice to go from summer to fall.
So I'm really glad.
You know, this time of year, it might be sort of nice to stop at FUWAMOCO Cafe and get maybe a yummy drink from us.
Like Chilipachino.
I recommend it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, please let us know if you see Pero around again.
Maybe give your eyes a bit of a rub first.
And don't forget to use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
I don't doubt this Ruffian though.
You don't?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't really... Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, I think it's been pretty good recently.
A lot of celebratory times.
Big celebrations, things to be happy about.
But it still continues!
Because... Kyaotsu!
Ai-senpai, Fauna-senpai, Kronii-senpai, they're having their 3D showcase this weekend!
Are you as excited as we are?
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
You excited?
I'm looking forward to seeing them move their 3D bodies, you know, doing
Whatever they want, you know.
All the things that they've been dreaming of.
It's exciting, you know.
I think, personally, we always really like it when there's a lot of singing and dancing, so... That's kind of a selfish wish.
We want to see them both sing and dance their original songs.
Especially Fauna-senpai's Let Me Stay Here.
It was really nice at 4th Fest, right?
We wanna see it again.
Original songs are always good, you know?
But we're wishing our senpai an amazing 3D showcase!
We'll be watching!
We'll be there!
So make sure, Ruffians, that you're there too, okay?
You know, 3D showcase only happens once, you know?
So... BAU BAU!
Wow, yesterday we had our first Twitter speech, right Moco-chan?
And doing it, you know, we did a lot of tidying here and there, getting rid of the fluff and the fuzz.
And we also used the vacuum a little bit, right?
But there's also another vacuum.
And for some reason, the Ruffians are really interested in it!
Instead!
Cuz I said I would.
I drew a picture of him.
There he is!
Wait, Moco-chan, you usually only draw pictures of like, other members or senpai.
This kind of makes it feel like the vacuums are senpai, no?
No, it's just a coincidence.
Oh, it's a coincidence.
Yeah, it's a coincidence.
He's not our senpai.
I mean, he has been around for a while, but... I think he was a gift maybe from Mama Puppy or Papa Puppy when they didn't need him anymore, but... I don't think he was too happy with us, because he sort of gave up before we were able to use him too much.
Just kind of came here and then... Didn't really do anything.
He looks like he has energy, but...
He doesn't work.
No, not anymore.
So for now, he'll just keep in his spot.
Until he needs to go away, right?
Is that okay though?
It's kind of nice to have an empty spot.
He'll just hang around.
Just for now.
He has a spirit.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
Rest well, Vacuum.
Rest well.
Yeah, it might be his retirement home.
Maybe his retirement spot.
Should we have a party?
This is good enough.
We made an appearance on FUWAMOCO Morning.
Okay.
So any more and we'll go to...
It's...it's...vacuum head.
You're good now, you're not curious anymore.
Right?
Right!
Don't want to bit on him.
And what's important is that we have another light vacuum that's easy to use.
And here's the one that you heard.
Just sometimes it's not the strongest against the fluff and the fuzz.
We need heavy duty.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
There's been a bit of another misunderstanding, but this time, you know, it's not my fault.
It's not though.
It's Ruffians.
It's not!
But, you know, I had nothing to do with it this time.
But actually, I didn't really understand this too much at first.
So, I don't know.
Somehow...
Ruffians, you know, last FUWAMOCO Morning was Miss Bird Anniversary, right?
And Moco-chan drew a picture of all our senpais.
I did my best!
Yeah, and somehow, I think there were a lot of Ruffians that thought that Ina-senpai looks a little bit strange.
Right!
I did my best.
Don't laugh!
What?
She doesn't look weird.
No.
This is how she looks all the time.
Right.
Are you using your brain?
How does it look strange?
It looks exactly the same as the other Missing Council members that I drew.
Right, right.
You know you have her eyes.
Her eyes?
And then her mouth.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think Moco-chan, I think maybe some Ruffians are getting confused because the collar kind of looks like the mouth, you know?
Maybe, you know, like, and then there's like a mustache?
No.
And maybe the mouth is now a nose?
You have to use your brain, okay?
A smile would've helped.
See, that Ruffian's a bit confused.
Why?
Dina-senpai is smiling.
It's a big smile, right?
Yeah!
It's a big smile!
Not a no.
It's an upturned smile.
Why would I ever draw Ina-senpai weird?
You know, I want to draw her peaceful and resting eyes, you know, just like her.
Yeah.
And a big smile.
Big smile.
Make it very cute.
She doesn't look sad!
She looks happy!
Peaceful!
You know it!
Ruffians, you too.
You need to use your eyes and your brain, okay?
Wait, that's the most... Yeah, the... The nice... The nice...
The nose that all the Ruffians are seeing, that's the mouth!
And the eyes are like... And then the collar!
The collar is on the neck!
It's not a moustache!
Not a moustache... Do you see it?
Go and see it like that!
See it directly!
Do you get it now, Ruffians?
There is no nose!
Forget about the nose!
Look at the proper Ina-senpai now.
Use your brain and look at it.
If you're still a bit confused, look at Ina-senpai, and then look at Moco-chan's drawing, and then it should be all good, right?
BAU BAU.
You don't see it?
You just see a cute Ina-senpai?
Happy!
Happy, right, Moco-chan?
Do you see a cute Moco-chan?
Why?
Not anymore because it's not there, but... Why?
Oh!
I heard Ina-senpai.
Is there a cute Moco-chan here?
Is that what you're asking?
I'm hard.
Yes.
Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I don't think I can continue FUWAMOCO Morning if it's like this.
Maybe we should just go to it.
No, no, no.
It's not that time yet, Moco-chan.
It's not that time yet.
It's your fault.
My fault?
No, Ruffians.
But you're at fault.
Why am I at fault?
Cute!
Okay.
I guess we can continue then.
Moco-chan, you're so childish sometimes.
I'm not!
It's very important.
It's my feelings, okay?
That's true, feelings are very important.
Wow, Ruffians!
We keep on hearing more and more Ruffians mentioning that you're kind of surprised at how FUWAMOCO operates.
You know, how surprisingly we're on time, we're very consistent with our schedule.
Yeah, you should know that by now.
Right!
You know, we have a certain way that we like to do things.
Yeah, you know we always make sure to start our stream like 5 minutes before the hour.
To start on exactly the right time.
Release our schedule in advance.
That way you can make plans too.
It's just how we do things, you know?
You know, this is how we feel we can best protect your smile.
You know, this also kind of shows how much you mean to us too, right?
You know, we know life isn't easy, so we thought, at the very least, that this might make it a bit easier for you to play with us and to fit us into your everyday, you know?
But you know, it's also something that we felt, too, before.
So I wanted to explain to you a bit.
So, I guess...
For us, I guess particularly me, I was a big fan of a tiny, small idol theater that would stream live stream performances.
So they would do the performance, but they would stream it as well.
And when they did live stream it, it would be around 3 or 4 AM in the Northwest Passage.
So, it was very, very early.
Very early.
But I really wanted to watch it!
And be a part of it no matter what!
So, even though less than 10 people were watching the stream, I would be there.
And... Even though it... It was a live stream, but you know, the stream quality... It was really, really low.
So often, you couldn't make out the idols' faces.
But you know, the audio was good.
So, it was worth it.
And...
The worst part was there was no archive.
Never ever ever.
So you know, I would have to wake up in order to watch.
There was no other option.
No option.
And they streamed around 5 days a week.
And I watched it like that for around 2 to 3 years.
2 to 3 years.
But you know what?
It ended up being really frustrating.
Moco-chan, you've been pretty grumpy some days.
Yeah, because a lot of times they would start late.
Like maybe halfway through the set or even not at all for almost weeks on end.
And there would never be an explanation.
So, it would make me really upset.
But if it did go live, it was really really good and it was really awesome.
And sometimes if there's a special event, it would usually mean that there is no stream.
But sometimes, just sometimes, they would stream the special event.
And it was amazing, so I would never know if they were going live or not.
Right.
But you want to make sure that you're this way.
Don't miss it if you do.
And you know sometimes they would forget to turn off the stream.
But all I knew that even if they weren't streaming, it was going on.
That's the most frustrating part, right?
It's going on!
They could turn on the camera, but they aren't!
So, and then if I watched, then I could start my day with a big burst of energy, you know?
So, it was really nice.
I enjoyed the two to three years.
Even though it was kind of ups and downs, right?
But you know, sadly, they started to turn on the stream less and less.
And eventually I just gave up after hoping for a stream for months and months and months.
But you know, because of that, we're like we are now!
You know, we learned how important it is to be on time!
You're trusting us.
You want to be here to support us.
And if we aren't here as we promised, then you'll be sad.
And we definitely don't want to disappoint you, so if we can do this to show to you how we feel through our actions and not just words, we're gonna do it!
It means a lot to us.
You being here.
And that's why, you know, we said that if we were to oversleep or we made a mistake with our schedule, that it would devastate us because it really, really would.
We know the feelings really well.
Yeah.
But we're doing our best!
We might make mistakes.
If that ever does happen, please be really, really gentle with us, okay?
Because FUWAMOCO, we won't be good.
We won't be good.
But we know the feelings, so... We'll do our best.
Thank you, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
I think it's time to find out who is the Doggie of the Day today.
Let's see.
It's Aspen!
Aspen!
I've been having the most comfy, most cozy nap in the summer.
I'm not jealous at all.
Right?
It'd be nice to switch places with Aspen.
Ruffians, wouldn't it just be nice to be Aspen for a day?
I'm so sleepy now.
See ya.
Alright.
Let me switch places.
Such a cute and...
Cozy and strong Doggie of the Day.
I mean Aspen is a strong name after all.
Right?
Like the tree.
Right.
Strong tree.
And also a very strong dog.
A very good doggy.
You know, Aspen's the Doggie of the Day.
You sort of look like that when you sleep.
To me?
Yeah.
Wait, wait, is that being mean to Aspen?
No, Aspen looks cute.
Oh, so I look cute when I say things?
Not as cute as Aspen.
Which is it?
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Aspen BAU BAU?
Definitely a deep, big BAU BAU.
Big BAU BAU.
BAU!
I like that one a lot!
Is that a big and deep BAU BAU?
I think it's good.
Especially the BAU BAU after getting...
It's a good rest.
Why?
Sleepy BAU BAU.
You know, I think Aspen, Aspen's a really good buddy.
Reminds us about, you know, the importance of getting a good rest.
About recharging your battery, you know?
Just about enjoying the little things in life.
Like a good zombie going across the sofa.
Doesn't sound like a dog.
He doesn't sound like a frog.
It's a big deep BAU BAU, okay?
Deep BAU BAU, yeah.
You know, I think it's important to have a buddy like Aspen who shows us the important things in life.
Right?
I hope that you're able to cuddle up with Aspen there.
That would be nice.
Toasty dog.
Thank you!
BAU BAU BAU!
Wow, today Moco-chan really is this ruffy and good.
Let's see!
De-den!
Bananas.
Two bananas.
Twin bananas.
What part of this is an uneventful walk to the grocery store?
You got twin bananas!
They're cute!
I don't know, at first I thought maybe you found the bananas at the grocery store.
But, you know, kind of looking at the background, it seems like maybe you found them along your way.
They look like banana trees, right?
That's really cool.
As soon as you said bananas, I thought of Donkey Kong.
Right?
Bananas!
Maybe this Ruffian lives in Donkey Kong Country.
Maybe not.
That might not be the safest.
Too many enemies, too much stuff to jump.
But the twin bananas look so cool!
And maybe a little bit delicious too.
Did you eat them?
That would be amazing!
You know, just being able to pick up bananas and then eat them.
I wanna know, did you eat the twin bananas?
I'm curious.
What would it taste like?
Banana peels.
You know Ruffians, sometimes maybe it's a bit hard to get outside and go for a walk, but if you have like a little goal, whether you know it's a grocery store, or maybe... FUWAMOCO Cafe!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Cafe to see like the water or something pretty, maybe it'll help you get going a little bit easier!
Right?
So next time you're like, I should probably go for a walk, but I don't know if I want to.
Give yourself a goal.
Yeah.
And then go put on your shoes and go!
We're glad you had a beautiful walk!
BAU BAU!
I'm really curious about how the banana tasted though.
Are the bananas?
Is it sweet or sour?
Right.
Sour banana.
Well, what's our Question of the Day today?
De-den!
I was inspired by your Japanese class with Albert to study a little harder with Japanese.
But sometimes I do get a little stuck on what to focus.
FUWAMOCO-sensei, what do you recommend to use to study to become fluent?
It's a good question.
First,
Ganbatte!
Ganbatte ne!
We understand what you mean by having a hard time focusing on what to study.
It can be a bit overwhelming, right?
I think it's best to just take things little by little at first.
Don't try to force yourself to learn kanji when you're still just getting used to it.
Hiragana katakana still.
I mean that's why for us it took us two years to learn Hiragana katakana.
But for us we really drilled it in so then there's no problems ever.
Right.
And then so when we started learning kanji it was really tough you know because trying to understand it, how it works, kun yomi, oni yomi, different readings.
Kanji is good, though.
It's good, but don't be like, ah, there's so many kanji I have to start now.
Just take it little by little, you know?
But as we're figuring out what to study first, I think we recommend the Genki textbook series.
If you want a bit more structure, you know?
Yeah, you know, I think it'll help you kind of learn at a good pace and not overwhelm you with too many things.
Face-friendly.
Yeah, yeah.
I think maybe refer it
The door is good too.
Yeah, but yeah, no pressure.
Just have fun.
Little by little, you know?
If you stress yourself out and you don't have fun with it, you're not gonna continue, you know?
So, just have fun!
Do your best!
Make mistakes!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I know it's the weekend, but this still means you can make submissions to the hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning.
We're still looking for more Pero Sightings.
Doggie of the Day.
We want to hear more about your works that you're going on.
And questions!
Questions too!
Please ask us lots of questions.
I think there might be a lot of Ruffians asking with the hashtag Help FUWAMOCO.
That's good too!
But for FUWAMOCO Morning, I think we most appreciate it with the hashtag
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Moco-chan.
Do you know what our next game is?
We have... De-den!
We have Mario Kart 8 to launch with all of us!
Yeah!
Our first time driving, right?
It's time for us to hit the road and get driving because we need to beat Abyss, you know.
We gotta beat them.
We'll use the items.
But I think just driving fast, driving carefully is good.
Fuwawa is gonna drive this time, right?
Moco-chan, you too.
Can I play?
Yeah, you can play.
Am I allowed?
You're allowed.
We talked about it a bit yesterday, but our goal is to beat Biboo.
But I think, you know, first we kind of need to brush up, get a bit prepared.
You know, we want to crush Biboo.
Yeah, crush her!
Crush the rock!
Let's practice!
We're gonna do our best to practice and prepare a little bit and then that way, we can make you Ruffians proud.
Hopefully.
I might not be as good at Mario Kart as I was at Apex, but...
I'll try!
BAU BAU!
And upcoming next!
I schedule!
Next, shortly after I collab with , we also have a stream.
A game.
We're playing Kanji the Game!
More studying.
Yeah, more studying, right?
This one is going to be at a very different time from our usual streams.
But there will be an archive so don't worry if you can't catch it.
We're going to be studying some really tough kanji and trying to read them as they come at us.
But, it might be really tricky.
We expect to fail a lot.
And you know, with that, we'll learn a lot too.
We'll learn a lot.
In a little bit, we'll be doing a live stream in kanji!
FUWAMOCO is the worst at kanji, but I think this game will be an opportunity for us to learn.
I think we should do it as if it's a study session.
So please,
We're gonna do our best!
After that we have Sakura Boys 5.
I'm really really looking forward to Ruffians.
Please join us.
It's very comfy.
FUWAMOCO Morning Episode 20 is going to be coming to an end now, Moco-chan.
It's been so fast.
Another week of FUWAMOCO Morning.
Another week together with the Ruffians.
Thank you for joining us.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
BAU BAU!
Aka Lemon!
Kellen!
BAU BAU!
Aiji!
Santa Ghost!
BAU BAU!
Pokimane!
Rush!
BAU BAU!
Lillian!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!